how was the crunchyroll anime awards
compared to that do you really want to
go into that
i mean one day i came back in my room
and there was a trash bag full of stuff
that wasn't mine
can you believe that i went in my hotel
my hotel room who went in there
i don't know i caught them up and i'm
like hey there's uh just a
just a giant bag of trash in my room uh
what's up with that and they're like
really
they're like they didn't believe me i'm
like yeah i'm like come come
the maids probably clean well yeah what
i think they did is the maids were
cleaning and they just forgot about it i
didn't care
yeah yeah they gave me a letter that was
like dear sea dog sorry that we left
trash in your room
and i was like why is it sea dogs
probably the name they put on the like
no it was connor because i checked in
with my real name and i know
the guy must have known or something it
was weird as [ __ ] because then he gave
me another bottle of wine
but it was like a terrible hotel screw
cap
i'm like this is i won't even cook with
this [ __ ] like
no offense like it's just garbage wine i
mean i'm not picky but even i knew that
but how was the how was the actual
awards
yeah how was it for you because we both
we both went on different years
how was it i mean the i imagine it's the
same for you the best aspect was just
chatting to the other creators yeah like
uh
it felt like a holiday where you just
got to like meet other creators chipotle
although i kept i i was like because we
would all eat lunch together right and i
was like
chipotle i want chipotle and then uh one
of the i forgot her name from ign
uh i think she was hispanic and she was
like no chipotle is garbage all right
i'm like listen
i come from a place well recently where
they don't have any chipotle or met you
know how hard it is to find a burrito
bigger than like your index finger in
this country impossible
i think out of every cuisine mexican is
one of the hardest to find in japan yeah
i want a burrito that like [ __ ] kills
me so anyway that's the yeah i had
it was nice having lunch with them sorry
i'm getting on the run but yeah
it was really cool their offices were
cool they'd made it into like yeah you
got to see their offices didn't didn't
they
yeah it was cool i mean i felt like a
little extra like i don't know i yeah
there was a lot of free lacroix i didn't
really care for lacroix
millennials right i think it's like the
mean drinks the most disgusting thing
is is that like white claw no no no no
lacroix is like
it's like salty water right flavored
sparkling water so yeah
oh it was weeks i think you went two
years in a row yeah and
i didn't go to the one where they were
streaming at the twitch headquarters
were they streaming on the twitch club
they were streaming their office oh okay
so there was like
a back room with a small crowd of about
a hundred people
yeah and it was fine i i really got
bored of how many times he had to
practice
how many times did you have to rehearse
because we need time we only had to
rehearse once
jesus what what were they rehearsing i i
think it was for the host
uh obviously he had a lot of lines like
for me it was easy i just
during the rehearsals by the way i mean
gone okay so i got to tell the story
right
so they they were like they they wanted
us to have a mixture of scripted and do
your own stuff so yeah
as i think it should be right like i
want to be on track but i also want to
you know be myself
so they would ask me a question that was
connor who do you think is best girl
and um during this story
during during rehearsals right i never
said like anything even remotely me me i
was like oh yeah like rem
yeah yeah and then i texted gone like an
hour before the show started i was like
yo give me
the worst girl give me the worst best
girl and i will dead ass say this
like straight face in front of all these
people like i'll do it yeah i'll do it
on the twitch stream i don't know
because i thought i want to make this
funny yeah in a good way that wasn't
[ __ ] with crunchyroll
that we could get a bit of laughter out
of it and i said nina from code gears
that was that was
that was the first name that came to
mind so
i i remember i said that joke and
[ __ ] crafts like
no one thought i watched the stream
yeah i was pissing myself i was [ __ ]
pissing myself thought to myself because
i knew no one was gonna laugh at this
joke right and i just taught myself i
was like the twitch
twitch chat they're gonna love it yeah
chat's gonna love this i don't mind
i'll just put up with the awkward
silence for like one second i was
watching the twitch
stream and the moment you said that i
died which chat was [ __ ] loving it
yeah yeah but like the crowd and the
audience and everyone's there
i remember i remember the moment i said
it right for some reason
jacob from faku was in the crowd and i
just made eye contact with jacob and he
looked like this
and i was like i was like and then i
think i made like a
joke or something i made something like
try and segue it and it didn't work very
well obviously but i didn't give a [ __ ]
it made for a great clip because it was
like so perfectly timed with my stream
because i was like
yeah i told conor to say nina and as
soon as i said that you said you said it
and it was just like the most perfectly
timed moment i could ever hope for
yeah okay well
is
yeah it was it was good i mean it was uh
it was fun i mean i
got to we hung out in like the like
green room or whatever and it was chill
just
chatting with uh i remember i chat with
prozy d a lot really cool guy
yeah um that man knows his anime he
knows a lot of amazon he knows so much
because i had a similar conversation
with him and i'm like
man you know more anime than most annie
tubers
[Applause]
he was just hit this room and it was
silent then you would just hear someone
playing the [ __ ] love life
just prozy sitting there like this he's
a love liver yeah oh he's a hard yeah
yeah it's so i love it when like when he
would talk because it would be like
whenever prose d
talked everyone in the room was like yes
pro cd well i'll listen to you he's such
a commanding voice yeah
he's amazing who has the deeper voice in
real life it's like just two mumbles
about talking because he's like i'll
give mcdonald's yeah i'll get mcdonald's
the sub with this conversation is
ridiculous
it was overall it was good i think the
the parts i remember the most were like
not the actual
like awards yeah i remember the same i
don't remember anything or what
happened was that when i was on stage
because i remember um when i was on
when i was in the country giant crowd on
this it was a big [ __ ] crowd
like how big was your crowd like no more
than a hundred
right because we were like they rented
out a whole stage in la or something
they had like a
red carpet which is like an orange
carpet it was like
it was charming about like it was
because it was still like a small scale
event but they really tried to
dress this up to look like something
official and
you know there was a lot of technical
difficulties and mess and mess up but
that's probably like you know you know
they were if you watched the streams the
technical difficulties in that year were
glorious but they
were they made for like great meme
material it was like charming in its own
way because
it wasn't like the game awards it wasn't
the [ __ ] oscars but you know they
tried their best and i think
for what they had they did like a pretty
decent job yeah
b plus for effort yeah i think it's i
think they said that they wanted to dial
it back this year to make it a
little more like have personalities
shine through a bit more but
it's it's still hard because i think you
know the sometimes you know some people
aren't as good
on stage as others yeah right is that
your first time like kind of
hosting i wasn't really doing anything
he was literally just sitting on a couch
yeah cracking jokes i don't really get
to the only thing i was nervous about
was cracking that joke like everything
because i knew that was gonna i knew
i knew no one would laugh but i didn't
mind but other than that i really don't
mind doing stuff like that that's fun
like
i remember the only the only weird thing
that happened when i was on stage
um was i was with uh i was standing next
to lily because i was uh hosting with
lily peachy when i was presenting my
awards
and so i was staying at the bride's
bright lights and all i heard was
and i thought someone said i love you
guys and i and i shout out in a crunchy
world awards
i love you too man and then i watch the
vods
and the guy shouts out i love you lily
i mean i don't think anyone noticed it
but yeah i thought i thought you were
just screaming for us
that guy when they did the final award
at archangel anime awards they had like
a giant like what is it called the
[ __ ] thing they opened what's it
what okay no i think it is they all had
sake that's part of the story but they
had like the big boxes that we had the
like the the names of the winners in oh
yeah the anime of the year had like a
giant one
oh yeah yeah there's i don't know i
don't know what they're called i know
what they're talking about
the giant one they were like yeah okay
everyone's gonna go on stage and we have
uh fake sake for you it's water and i
was like oh cool cool cool
so i have it right and i'm smelling it
like next to lily i think you can see me
and lily
in the vault it's like visual confusion
because we do it and we're like that's
that's [ __ ] sacking they told us it
was [ __ ] water
and then like me and lily are like god
that's [ __ ] vile
yeah that's gross they lied to us
cut you all what if i was like allergic
to alcohol
they they gave you free alcohol and you
didn't even know
yeah because there was there was alcohol
right after the after surprise alcohol